Researcher Martin pushed the deck against
the door, hoping it would hold long enough
for him to find an alternate escape route.
He wasn’t thinking about the long term,
he couldn’t afford to.
With the Foundation’s global reach, he’d
never truly escape them, never be able to
make it away, condemned to spend the rest
of his life on the run from the organization
he’d devoted his life to.
It was too overwhelming to even attempt to
reckon with that, especially with the pounding
of a fist against the door.
He scrabbled around, opening windows to try
and see if there was a safe way down.
Technically none of this was his fault, at
least in his mind.
The administrative login information he’d
used to access the file shouldn’t have been
left so easy to find; that was just poor cyber
security on the Foundation’s part.
Researcher Martin had been tasked with compiling
information on SCP-001, one of the most infamous
anomalies ever encountered in the Foundation’s
long and storied history… or multiple of
them, at least.
What Martin had come to learn was, there were
numerous entries within the Foundation’s
files that all acted as proposals for SCP-001.
Some were creatures, the typical kind of anomalous
entities the Foundation dealt with on a regular
basis.
But some of the proposals focused on more
abstract anomalies… and somehow, those were
more existentially terrifying than any evil
godlike being bent on destroying reality.
Theories about the very source of anomalies
themselves, that their very existence might
have been pre-determined by some otherworldly
force.
Then there were the other proposals that named
parts of the Foundation as the true SCP-001.
Those seemed to suck Researcher Martin in
like a vortex, dragging him down a deep, dark
rabbit hole that made him start to question
everything he thought he knew about working
for the SCP Foundation.
And the one that toppled him into a full-blown
conspiracy-obsessed stupor that there was
no coming back from: the Noir Box Proposal.
The weighted head of a battering ram splintered
the wooden surface of the door, spraying fragments
over the room.
The table propped up to keep it shut toppled
under the force of entry, as a squad of shadowy
figures in full black combat gear rushed inside.
The Mobile Task Force surrounded the cowering
researcher, keeping their weapons trained
on him.
Researcher Martin, pleading for his life,
started gesturing to the walls of the room
around him, that had been plastered with hastily
scrawled diagrams and equations.
Martin tried desperately to find some concise,
easy-to-understand way of explaining to the
soldiers what he’d uncovered.
They only picked up on a few words like ‘many
worlds hypothesis’ and ‘splitting universes’
but ultimately they didn’t follow what he
was saying – and weren’t sent there to
hear him out.
All the MTF had been told was that Researcher
Martin had breached Foundation security and
now posed a risk of exposing sensitive information
about SCP-001.
There was only one path of recourse: termination.
However, unbeknownst to them, Doctor Martin
was fine.
At least a version of him was, one who never
learned about the Noir Box Proposal for SCP-001,
and hadn’t gone mad trying to unravel its
mysteries.
Instead, he was a respected higher ranking
member of the Foundation who was alive and
well… in a completely different timeline.
The formation of the SCP Foundation has always
been shrouded in mystery, with nobody really
knowing what the true origin of the organization
is and what is merely just a cover story left
in the archives to keep the truth hidden.
SCP-001, the Noir Box Proposal at least, might
hold the answers to the questions surrounding
how the Foundation came to be – three times
over.
Known as the Tindalos Trinity, the file pertaining
to this anomaly is buried deep in the SCP
Foundation’s database, under layers upon
layers of encryption and security clearance
requirements.
It requires someone at the very top level
of the Foundation to access, a member of either
the Overseer Council… or the Foundation’s
High Command… or Overwatch?
But wait, what are those?
Aren’t they all the same thing?
Well, yes and no.
The exact name of the high-ranking secretive
group that runs the Foundation has often been
interchangeable, whether they’re known as
the O5 Council, the Overseer Council, et cetera.
But what if that wasn’t just many different
names for the same governing body, but actually
separate names for alternate versions of the
ones who control the SCP Foundation.
Allow us to explain.
All three of these groups - the Overseer Council,
High Command, and Overwatch – have come
to a consensus that SCP-001 is an anomaly
that connects to do with the Foundation’s
very origin.
They believe that the founder of the SCP Foundation,
also known as SCP-001, was anomalous in some
way that caused them to interact with time
in an unusual way.
The triumvirate of councils are in agreement
that around the time that the SCP Foundation
was formed, three distinct timelines were
generated, given the anomalous nature of the
organization’s founder.
Each one of these timelines drastically altered
the nature of SCP-001, featuring a different
version in each one.
In the first, commonly known as Timeline HC
– where the Foundation is run by a High
Command – SCP-001 was an anomalous human
corpse.
This timeline’s SCP-001 still exhibited
all the behavioral characteristics of a normal
human being, but could additionally replicate
itself at an erratic, uncontrollable rate
– usually when performing tasks that could
have multiple possible outcomes.
SCP-001 in Timeline HC also interacted anachronistically
with its environment, passing through solid
matter that predated it or would outlast it.
So, it had to be contained in a room that
was constructed before it existed as an anomaly.
This timeline’s SCP-001 was responsible
for conceiving the idea for the SCP Foundation,
and was able to promote a significant interest
in the organization.
However, they were assassinated before the
Foundation was officially codified, with the
culprits being a version of Mobile Task Force
Alp 0, who are believed to have originated
from either of the other two timelines.
While this seems to have been done to deter
the Foundation forming in this timeline, it
seems to have had the opposite effect.
Despite the assassination of SCP-001, occurring
before the official formation of the SCP Foundation
in Timeline HC, this version of the Foundation
was successfully codified by the thirteen
members of what they referred to as High Command.
Given the anomalous circumstances around the
death of SCP-001, it provided a catalyst for
the organization to immediately establish
itself as this timeline’s protection against
the threat posed by anomalous entities.
The body of SCP-001 was placed in the building
that had been its childhood home, securing
it somewhere that predated them to negate
their anomalous properties.
This made them the first anomaly contained
by Timeline HC’s version of the SCP Foundation,
posthumously garnering them the official designation
of SCP-001.
So, that’s the first of our three timelines
at play.
The events that unfold in the second are considerably
different.
In this timeline – Timeline OC – the Foundation
was initially created by a different SCP-001.
This entity, referred to primarily as The
Founder (appropriately enough) was a human
being known to possess anomalous temporal
abilities.
The Founder was known to also be immortal,
showing no visible signs of aging and with
a resistance to external damage that prevented
him from being directly killed.
Any injuries he sustained could be healed,
but only at the same rate typical of an average
human being.
The temporal side of his anomalous properties
pertained to predicting the future.
The Founder was able to, with an inarguable
level of precision and accuracy, forecast
events before they occurred.
His foresight, it appeared to the Foundation,
was not inciting these events to happen as
he predicted them, however everything he ever
predicted would occur became an inevitability,
impossible to delay, avert or alter through
any means.
During the events of Timeline OC – and as
his preferred nickname implies – the Founder
was the sole figure responsible for establishing
this version of the SCP Foundation.
In this course of events, the O5 Council of
this timeline were known as the Overseer Council.
It was, however, while he was in the process
of establishing the organization, that things
started to go awry.
Whether he was able to predict this occurrence
or not is unknown, although it seems to have
corresponded with the MTF Alp 0 assassination
of SCP-001 in the other timeline, Timeline
HC.
In Timeline OC, at the same time as the assassination
in Timeline HC, all the Founder began to exhibit
his anomalous temporal properties in front
of the original members of Overseer Council.
However, it should also be noted that there
was no recorded presence of MTF Alp 0 in Timeline
OC.
Believing the Founder to be a potential danger
to the Foundation they had all helped to create,
the founding Overseer Council classified him
as an anomalous threat.
They immediately devised a set of containment
measures for the Founder – now designating
him as SCP-001, the first anomaly contained
by this timeline’s version of the Foundation.
He was placed within a standard humanoid containment
cell, and given regular meals, while personnel
were forbidden to communicate with him.
Given his role in establishing the Foundation
in this version of events, SCP-001 is, naturally,
in favor of containing and analyzing anomalies.
However, not when that includes him, and insisted
that he be released.
According to one of his predictions for forthcoming
events, he requested to be allowed to build
a device, but refused to elaborate on the
intended purpose of it.
SCP-001 even refused to allow other members
of Foundation personnel to construct the device
on his behalf for testing purposes.
The third of these timelines is referred to
as Timeline OW, wherein the leading body of
the Foundation are known as Overwatch.
Here, just like the previous iterations of
its history, the description of SCP-001 and
their role in forming the SCP Foundation differs.
In this timeline, SCP-001 is an anomaly that
consists of two distinct parts.
The first of these is a figure not dissimilar
from the Founder.
Referred to as SCP-001-1, this person is also
a functionally immortal human, who doesn’t
age and can’t heal rapidly from damage.
SCP-001-1 also advocates for securing and
analyzing anomalies, however, this includes
himself, as he doesn’t object to his own
containment.
Or that of the second component of this SCP-001.
Known as SCP-001-A, this device is capable
of accurately calculating any and all possible
outcomes of any event that is input into it.
Unlike the Founder, who seemed to possess
a foresight able to predict the only inevitable
outcome of the future, SCP-001-A is able to
account for the possibility of multiple potential
futures, even down to accounting for how its
own predictions could potentially influence
or alter outcomes.
In laymen’s terms, at least one of the eventualities
predicted by SCP-001-A will always be accurate.
Unless the predictions are to do with its
own future, or the future of SCP-001-1.
In this instance, the device will always produce
one of two assumptions that are incorrect.
Either that SCP-001-1 was killed after an
assassination attempt and never constructed
SCP-001-A. But that’s impossible, after
all, SCP-001-A exists, it’s already been
made in this timeline.
The other incorrect prediction it can give
is that SCP-001-1 also exhibits the same anomalous
properties as the prediction machine – more
akin to the Founder – and that SCP-001-A
was never constructed in the first place.
But again, that can’t be right… in this
timeline, anyway.
According to records, within Timeline OW,
their version of the Founder – who is, of
course, SCP-001-1 – encountered a version
of Mobile Task Force Alp 0 from one of the
other timelines.
They presented the Founder of the OW timeline
with detailed blueprints for the construction
of SCP-001-A.
The device’s completion coincided with the
assassination in Timeline HC and the corresponding
anomalous incident in Timeline OC.
After this point, MTF Alp 0 departs from Timeline
OW.
This version of the SCP Foundation is then
created to study the device, SCP-001-A, with
this Founder and a group of his close friends,
who would become this Foundation’s Overwatch.
Following this initial research group’s
discovery of other anomalous phenomena that
threatened the rest of society, the team’s
goal expanded to research anomalies and protect
the world from the danger they posed.
However, the rest of the Overwatch began to
age at a natural rate, while the Founder didn’t
recognize this, he volunteered to be contained
and studied, thus becoming a component of
this timeline’s SCP-001.
Stepping back and looking at all of these
timelines, there seems to be a number of marked
similarities, particularly relating to how
the Foundation was established and how a figure
– usually the one who founded the organization
– possessed anomalous means of interacting
with time and temporality.
Under normal circumstances, interaction between
alternate timelines should be impossible.
But the preservation of information about
all three on the SCP Foundation’s database
has somehow enabled all three timelines to
communicate with each other.
Through exchanging intelligence via their
own versions of the database, all three iterations
of the Foundation across the three timelines
have learned that almost all of the anomalies
they have encountered since being established
are exclusive to their own timeline.
There are a total of seventeen anomalies that
have been confirmed to exist across the three
timelines.
But there’s a concerning factor in all of
this.
The presence of an anachronistic military
group referring to itself as MTF Alp 0.
This Mobile Task Force’s direct involvement
in the events of both Timeline HC – where
they assassinated SCP-001 – and Timeline
OW – where they provided schematics for
SCP-001-A – raises an awful lot of questions.
This MTF had to have been acting on orders
of the Foundation, but which version in which
timeline?
The consensus among the leading committees
of all three, the High Command, Overseer Council,
and Overwatch, is that at some unknown date
in the future, each of them will inevitably
send their own version of MTF Alp 0 back in
time to alter the Foundation’s past.
And in a sense, they’ve already done it
and seen how this altered the circumstances
in order to inadvertently create the Foundation.
But this poses the risk of one of these timelines
overwriting another, thus meaning all information
gathered by alternate iterations of the Foundation
could be lost.
So, putting their heads together, these Foundation
leading committees come to the conclusion
that they need to attempt to merge all three
timelines.
And it seems the way to do so is using the
device that Timeline OC’s Founder wanted
to build, and that Timeline OW’s Founder
was able to construct.
This device is how this proposal for SCP-001
was given its nickname; the Noir Box.
The intention of the Noir Box is to shunt
all three timelines into a stable, joint path,
like turning loose strands into a single length
of twine.
As such, the leading committees of all three
different timelines have agreed to share their
intel on how each of them can safely create
their own Noir Boxes, and all three will be
used to merge the timelines.
Every member of High Command, the Overseer
Council, and Overwatch sign off on it.
But whether or not the plan works is another
matter.
The fabric of time is delicate, and one wrong
move could tear everything apart…
Now check out “SCP-001 NOIR BOX PROPOSAL
- HATED CAESAR” and “SCP-001 OVERLORD
CENSURE” for more!